hi there Steve Kaufman here and today
I'm going to talk about the most
important thing in language learning and
that is enjoyment
enjoyment is not only the goal of
language learning enjoyment is how you
manage to succeed in language learning
and I'm going to talk about the five
stages of enjoyment because after all as
we go through learning the language we
are in different stages of either we're
beginning the language or we're starting
to get a hold of the language and there
are different kinds of enjoyment at
least that's how I experience language
learning so
when we begin the first stage
when we're starting to discover the
language at first it's all noise but
somehow as if by Magic what was noise
becomes words uh you start to be able to
read a little bit even though you listen
many many times and keep on missing the
same parts of what you're listening to
and and you look up words let's say on
link and you review them and you listen
again and but
it's exciting it's it's that excitement
of discovering something new and and
that's in the first stage
of learning a language that kind of
maintains me because so much of it is is
not meaning it's it's unclear and and it
just seems so strange at first and
particularly when I was learning Persian
and Arabic with different writing
systems it's so difficult at first
however there's that enjoyment that
excitement of sort of I'm embarking on
something new I'm going to learn this
what to me is an exotic language and and
I find that initial period very
enjoyable and so there is that first
period of enjoyment of discovering
something new but then after a while we
get tired of listening to the same stuff
over and over again there's a lot of
repetitive listening in the early stages
in order to get a you know to get a hold
of the new language so in that second
stage all of a sudden
what we have been listening to even
though we don't really understand it all
that well it's becoming familiar we're
going to we're going back to something
that's no longer brand new in fact it's
familiar still we understand 10 15
percent
it seems like there's an endless number
of words to learn but it's a familiar
environment and and I enjoyed that
challenge when I'm starting to get a bit
of a sense of the language and it's
familiar familiar sounds listening to
the same sounds that I don't understand
struggling with the same writing system
that still presents challenges uh but
it's a familiar environment I I miss it
when I'm away from it I enjoy going back
to it even as the language remains very
unclear for me I enjoy that second
period as we're starting to turn the
corner in the language
now the third period which is kind of
that long Plateau which for some people
can be a period of frustration for me
it's it's not a period of frustration
because I'm now in a situation where I
understand depending on the content
you know 20 30 40 50 of some content if
I go back to some of my earlier sort of
mini stories in link where I've heard
them so many times I understand seventy
percent eighty percent and every time I
listen I pick up something new of my old
beginner material and then I push myself
forward into new and more difficult
material and and I'm starting to feel
that I am going to be able to understand
that language even though the language
still is a bit opaque you know it's
still not really comprehensible but I
recognize that I understand a lot more
than I understood before I almost feel
as if I shouldn't understand it but I
don't fully I understand some words but
I can't get a sense of the whole meaning
but still it's enjoyable because I sense
that I'm on the verge of reaching you
know a level of of comfortable
comprehension I'm not there yet but I
think I'm gonna get there and so so that
sort of plateau period which is quite
long it seems there's an endless number
of words to learn
it doesn't bother me because I know that
if I continue with my good language
learning habits if I continue listening
and reading just as I've already
progressed from where I was before I
will continue to progress the brain is
getting used to the language the brain
is already much more used to the
language than it was in the previous
stages
now the fourth stage which is in many
cases you know as far as people go it's
as far as I have gone in a number of my
languages it's where I understand
eighty percent of most
uh language content of movies it can
vary but let's say 60 70 80 percent I
understand I'm comfortable if I'm in a
conversation with someone I can hold up
you know my end of the conversation I
understand what the person is saying I'm
able to get my meaning across sometimes
you know with mistakes or sometimes I
can't remember words and sometimes I
don't understand some of the things that
are said to me but by and large I am
functional in the language I met B2 call
it almost B2 I'm functional and if I
leave the language there I've got
something that I can come back to so
that's a sense of you know achievement
accomplishment it's it's for in many
languages it's the end of the line I
made it if I leave it and let it slide
into disuse if again I'm in a situation
where I need it I can bring it back so I
can take it off this is a language that
I have learned that doesn't mean I'm
perfect but I've learned it so that's
stage four of enjoyment now stage five
which is the ultimate is when you're
totally comfortable in the language you
understand the movies you can be in any
situation at any time you cannot speak
the language for two years and you come
back to it and you're just about where
you were when you left off this is like
I call it a C1 this is where I feel you
know and I can listen to literature I
Can Read Literature I can do whatever I
want in the language that is sort of the
ultimate now you don't have to achieve
that level in the language in order to
enjoy the process
of learning the language or to enjoy the
language I enjoy the language at the
beginning if I start another language
be Hindi or something I'm going to enjoy
that initial period of Discovery then
I'm going to enjoy that second stage
when it's familiar it's a familiar
struggle but it's a familiar environment
I don't mind that I enjoy that then when
I'm on that long Plateau where it seems
as if I'm not progressing and yet I'm
understanding more and more I feel as if
I should understand I almost understand
but I don't understand
uh but then the fourth stage is when I'm
kind of at almost at the final stage of
my journey I'm comfortable I'm happy I
can take it off it's mine but then with
some languages if I get the opportunity
I'll push myself through to that final
stage of enjoying enjoyment but all
stages are enjoyable and enjoying the
language learning process is not only
the key to success but it also should be
the goal so thank you for listening and
if you do my enjoy my videos please
um you know subscribe
and I'll leave you with uh a couple of
videos that I've done on a similar
subject in the past bye for now